you're watching white coming up on this
week's show do it yourself body science
how some people are hacking their health
kids camp the tech version we catch up
with bright young minds coding in their
summer holidays and we explore the
farthest reaches of space in our games
review welcome to swipe from summer camp
remember when school holidays used to be
all about getting outdoors and having
adventures well that was before postin
and java shook things up their computer
programming languages by the way the
kids here are mad about tech and later
on we'll be meeting a few of them but
before then and completely unrelated to
some accounts chris has been meeting
people going big on DIY health hacks we
saw this morning but already doctors it
for quick tech Crohn's disease sufferer
Michael Sears has had 25 bowel
operations since the age of 14 in 2011
he had a rare intestinal transplant
which means he now wears a colostomy bag
to collect his waist he became
frustrated with the quality of life it
gave him so he created a smart device to
improve things the product is a
connected sensor it's it's as you can
see with the clips on the outside of a
stoma bag and what it does is after
stoma bag fills there was resistance and
the sense of change of shape and it
sends a signal via bluetooth to your
phone so from a patient perspective you
can set multiple alarms to alert you as
your bag is filling all I did was going
internet and Google and I found the
sense of strip in an electronic game and
I had nine months in hospital for
transplant so I was able to hack
together a device Michael's not alone in
taking things into his own hands you can
see in the middle that device that
little structure squeezing out that's a
left ventricle when boiler engineer
towel Goldsworthy was diagnosed with a
life-threatening heart condition he used
3d printing to create a tailor-made
sleeve that's it
the aorta this protects it and stops it
from getting too big but is everyone
ready for patients to take the
initiative despite having some very
heavy weight medical physicians on board
we had some difficulty with the ethical
approval because the medical profession
is by nature conservative and of course
this is radical engineering something
with which they are not familiar these
are just some of the health hacks on
show at London's Science Museum it's
part of an exhibition that's showcasing
DIY biology something that's been around
for longer than you might think you go
back 100 150 years and everyone he was
by large he was a scientist was Whizzer
was an amateur essentially you know the
kind of invention of the the
professional scientist so to speak is a
you know that's a relatively new
phenomenon what who knows where we'll be
in the next century testing Chris
Creegan Sky News stay with us still to
come I'll be getting a lesson in vex
robotics that's coming right up after a
roundup of this week's tech news the
makers of Pokemon go say you'll be
banned for life if you cheat the
developers have updated the games Terms
of Service warning users who manipulate
the app will be kicked out some players
have been tricking the game into
believing they're in false locations to
get ahead Apple boss Tim Cook revealed
his job is sort of lonely this week but
he doesn't want sympathy he says CEOs
don't need it
in a rare interview marking his five
years at the helm of the company he told
the Washington Post of some of his
mistakes - including releasing a widely
criticized Apple Maps at Gamescom kicked
off this week increasingly becoming
known as the world's biggest gaming show
hundreds of thousands of fans arrived in
Cologne to see the latest offerings from
developers and as expected virtual
reality has been a strong feature this
year talking of which Facebook's oculus
rift is coming to the UK next month
European fans were able to start
pre-ordering the virtual reality headset
online this week but on September the
20th it'll hit shops in the UK it's not
cheap though setting you back five
hundred and forty nine pounds
in a bit we'll be taking the plunge in
our games review now the whole reason we
came to a children's summer tech cap was
to meet the children come on over let me
introduce you to Leo and Jane I can show
you what they're building guys hello
hello so talk to me about this creation
this is a sumo robot and we're gonna
make it so that when we battle another
robot over you you built see my robot
yeah yeah how long did it take to build
two days can we see in action she put it
on the floor I want to see see if we can
flip things over a new programmed it to
do that yes your parents know how to
code I show them a picture in there like
and in here it's all about music Rachel
hello can we have a chat about what
you're doing please this is a short
track that I'm doing to help me get used
to Ableton Ableton software software
shall we're using Ableton Live it looks
really complicated yeah I know but it is
don't hang of it yeah I'm getting the
hang of it now and what you have is
quite fun to play around and don't mix
so why did you opt for digital music
production skills of course like this on
your some holiday well one I think it's
really fun and I enjoy it and two I
think because I'm a singer it will
really help me with music producing my
songs self-produce yeah and because
guitar and piano are kind of like plain
old you can't really add much but with
software's like this you can really make
it more enjoyable no offense to any
fairness to all guitar of course so
you're gonna let us have a listen to
what you've been creating you play us
out
they're also learning about videogames
design here and while they're out on a
break here's Luke with our games review
I've seen things
a few things no man sky is an accident
venture survival game in which you
explore a procedurally generated
universe consisting of over 18
quintillion planets the game is based on
four pillars one is exploration then
their survival combat and trading the
aim is to get to the center of this
universe so to do so you land on planets
you explore discover new wildlife you
mind resources and then you trade all of
this to own currency with that currency
you upgrade your ship and then that
makes it easier to get to the center of
the universe it sounds fascinating and
there is absolutely no question that on
a technical level this is a huge
achievement and you will never have seen
anything like it in gaming having said
that it does become slightly repetitive
and for every alien brachiosaur you
encounter there's just another slightly
different space cow so jury's out on
this one but it truly is a spectacular
achievement
Abdo is an underwater adventure game
available for ps4 and PC and the name
actually means to know the ocean now if
you're seeing these pictures and you're
thinking the art direction looks
slightly familiar that's because the
creative director of this game was
actually also the art lead on journey
and flour and actually journey is a very
good diving off point for discussing
this game because they do show a lot of
similarities like journey the story is
buried and has to be discovered and it's
also very calming and poignant as a
beautiful score but unlike journey which
can be quite solitary experience their
oceans here are absolutely teeming with
life
you have manta rays or dolphins that you
can ride you have pulsating schools of
fish there's sharks there's crustaceans
and in the most moving scene you also
swim I to I with a massive blue whale
and it really is quite breathtaking it's
not the longest of games but if you've
ever wanted to explore the depth then
this is the perfect way to do it
DSX mankind divided is an action RPG
with stealth elements and the sequel to
2011's Deus Ex Human Revolution so trust
me when I say some of us have been
waiting a very long time for this game
it's set in a future where secret
societies and conspiracies are right and
at the crux of all of these issues is an
advanced technology called augmentations
which basically sees human beings have
implants that give them superhuman
abilities but when it comes to gameplay
there's also even more on offer the game
has come on leaps and bounds since human
Revolution mainly through the various
different ways you can explore levels
you can go through in a very very
aggressive combat ative style and use
your guns wherever you want or you can
take more stealthy approach and sneak
around and non-lethal EU take out your
opponents the open world hubs are
fantastically busy and bustling and feel
like a real world well the number of
side quests is through the roof the main
game alone should take you over 30 hours
to complete but if you're really in it
for the long haul and you just can't get
enough of Adam Jensen and his adventures
then you can go well as well beyond that
well that's it for this week but don't
forget you can watch any of our swipe
episodes on our YouTube playlist just
type in I new swipe and you can stay up
to date with all the latest tech news on
sky news on where mobile tablet catch up
sky cute and snapchat throughout the
week see you again next time bye bye